Hogwarts legacies trophy list has been
revealed and I hear you a lot of you are
asking the question should you look or
not how spoilery is it I put out a tweet
over on Twitter basically saying I would
not recommend looking however in this
video what I'm going to do is break it
down in different levels I'm going to
start just giving you the news there's
going to be no spoilers whatsoever here
just going to let you all know what has
happened how this leak came about and
then as we go through the video I am
going to be sharing the trophy list with
you but I will always be totally clear
when a spoiler is coming up so right now
you're totally in the clear no spoilers
whatsoever we're going to start with
just the news here so it all came about
from the epic games PC store so the
achievement list for Hogwarts Legacy
went live so while we can't say this is
100 official it did not come from WB did
not come from Avalanche but it is from a
highly credible Source I mean the epic
game store it is very likely that this
is in fact the final list for the game
it has already been picked up by a
number of websites including the one
where I read it is a site called
powerpyx.com and to be fair there are a
number of trophies here that are very
innocuous I mean it's just things that
you would expect it's no Major Spoilers
I do think there are a handful I would
say two to three that people really
probably don't want to know and then 10
to 15 or so that I don't think are Major
Spoilers but for someone who wants to go
and just completely blind they probably
wouldn't want to see these so just some
of the basic details here there are 46
trophies total there are no difficulty
trophies I know that's usually a
question for a lot of people and then
will it require multiple playthroughs
that's also a very common question I
think it probably will I can't say for
certain and I can't give you more
details without getting into the spoiler
section here but for those of you who
are curious I do think it will take
multiple playthroughs to get all right
so now we are going to shift into the
level one spoiler so I'm gonna put a
little bar here at the bottom I don't
consider these to be major at all I
think most of these are very obvious but
if you are someone who wants to go in
completely blind then now is the point
you would want to turn off the video all
right if you're still here we're going
to go through these now so the first one
is called the spell master and you get
this trophy for learning all the Spells
not a huge surprise then we have a forte
for achievement reach level 40 the Good
Samaritan complete all side quests
challenge accepted complete all tiers of
a challenge collector's edition complete
all collections a keen sense of spell
invoke ancient magic for the first time
so sounds like that's going to be a
story related one and then one called
loom for improvement I'm not sure if
that's actually supposed to be room for
improvement but you get that trophy for
upgrading a piece of gear then we have
the root of the problem stunned 10
different enemies using a mandrake next
going through the potions Brew every
type of potion after that put down Roots
grow every type of plant flew around the
world and I love that they spelled flu
f-l-o-o unlock all flu Flames after that
followed the butterflies and to get this
one you have to follow butterflies to a
treasure then we have rise to the
challenges defeat enemies in all battle
arenas so multiple battle arenas
seemingly confirmed then third times a
charm upgrade a piece of gear three
times a talent for spending spend five
Talent points Savvy spender spend all
Talent points the ends petrify the means
I love that title defeat a total of 50
enemies using petrificus totalus raising
expectations is the one after that and
to get this one you have to reach a
combo of 100 then we have finishing
touches use Ancient Magic on every enemy
in the game and then last but not least
for the level 1 spoilers is first class
student attend your first class so a lot
of obvious things there there may be
some things we can read into a little
bit more in the future but by and large
I don't think there's anything
significant in those spoilers I think
it's interesting but nothing significant
in terms of you know being some huge
spoiler that you're gonna hate that you
read okay after that now we are going to
shift into level 2 spoilers and these
again personally I don't feel like they
were a huge deal but they do have some
bits of information that Avalanche
hasn't made official things that we
haven't known publicly so far so there
are some things in here that you may
learn from either the title of a trophy
or the description of the trophy that
you may in fact did not want to know so
if you do not want to know the level 2
spoilers now is your time to hop off
this video this video is going to be
terrible for YouTube retention by the
way but who cares I want to make sure
that you guys don't get spoiled if you
don't want to so for level two spoilers
here now is your last chance and the
first one we have here is called the
sort who makes an entrance complete the
introduction and finish the Sorting
ceremony and I kind of debated with
putting this one in level one but since
we haven't had this kind of introduction
segment officially confirmed I thought I
would just go ahead and put it in level
two we pretty much kind of knew that
there was going to be some sort of
section before Hogwarts to kind of
introduce us to the game and that seems
to indicate that's what's going on here
and then the Sorting ceremony will be
how that little introduction sequence
ends after that we have the Seeker of
knowledge and for this one you have to
win the house cup now I put this one in
level two because during the gameplay
showcase they actually mentioned the
house Cup and the house point system and
they said that it's not a core gameplay
mechanic which I think it was good of
them to kind of get out in front of that
and explain hey this is not going to be
some huge deal however because of this
trophy achievement it is clearly going
to be a part of the story and so I'm
guessing that whichever house we choose
is going to just kind of automatically
win the house cup I don't know maybe
through the story sort of like Harry
Potter Story how Dumbledore is always
like we have a few extra points to a
ward maybe that's what's going on here
but I I mean I think this is a good one
because it's clear that hey the house
cup is going to be at least somewhat
part of the game maybe we don't have any
control over the outcome of it but then
again I'm kind of like also it's a
trophy so the way trophies and
achievements work is they always have
some that are just automatic you get
along the story and then they have
others that are various challenges and
things that you have to go out of your
way to do so it's kind of unclear to me
on if this one is a story one that we're
going to automatically get or if there's
a way to actually lose the house cup I
think that's the big question that I
keep coming back to is can we lose the
house cup or is this an automatic one
next we have the nature of the Beast
breed every type of Beast all right
after that we have one called the
avenging gazelle complete natsai onai's
relationship line so again I debated
with this one on going in level one
spoiler or level two I ultimately
decided with level two because of the
fact that they called it a relationship
line which I don't think we have heard
it referred to that before usually
they've been calling these characters
Companions and then there's also the
name of the trophy the avenging gazelle
I haven't been able to dig too deep into
it yet to figure out how that would tie
into the story or the gameplay but it
could be minor spoilery territory there
as well then we have one called The
Defender of dragons save a dragon my
guess is that this one is Story related
or possibly tied to Poppy's side quest
you know we see that shot in one of the
trailers where poppy is with us while we
are just I mean staring right at the
hybridium black dragon and then I'm
super excited about the next one because
it is called Demi guys dread find all
demiguice statues so we've been
wondering about side quests we've been
wondering about this kind of extra stuff
that we'll be able to do around Hogwarts
you know when we're not going to class
and doing the main story and so I am so
happy that they are going to have these
little Collectibles like this little
things that you have to go around and
find and the other cool thing about this
is that we've already seen some of these
if you think back to all of the footage
that we've seen how many demigay statues
to remember that we've seen so far
that's gonna be super fun uh the next
one is called Beast friends complete
poppy sweeting's relationship line so
again using that word relationship
rather than companion the title Beast
friends not a huge surprise we knew
poppy was going to be very key to the
Fantastic Beasts storyline of the game
after that we have one called a sallow
grave complete Sebastian sallow's
relationship line again the word
relationship and this one I put into
this category mainly because of the
title A sallow grave that worries me
that we have just been eased on how
Sebastian's questline is going to end I
mean I hope it's not Sebastian's grave
but we know his sister has a
debilitating curse and we know that he
is trying to find a cure for it in this
game and that we are a key part of that
after that we have one called flight the
good flight beat amelda's time in all
broom races so Imelda was a name that we
heard mentioned in the gameplay showcase
now I'll go ahead and tell you guys the
other reason I put the relationship line
ones here is because that's it those are
the only three relationship lines
mentioned which if you've been following
the channel for a while you know that I
said I I heard there would in fact be a
Ravenclaw companion and I gotta be
honest I I apologize to you guys because
it certainly seems like I may have
gotten inaccurate information on that or
if there is a Ravenclaw companion it is
not going to be fully fleshed out enough
to where they would warrant a trophy for
relationship line now we do know there
are ravenclaws in the game and even
ravenclaws that give us quests we saw
that in the gameplay Showcase with the
young first year Ravenclaw so I just
can't imagine that there is no not some
type of significant Ravenclaw character
I mean companion that we meet in this
game that will fight alongside us I
don't know if it's something that was
cut or maybe Imelda is the Ravenclaw
I've seen some people mention that as a
possibility as well Imelda is mentioned
of course in the trophies that one that
we just talked about with the broom
races but unless there's a hidden trophy
hidden achievement that we don't see and
honestly it's kind of disappointing if
there's not going to be a Ravenclaw
character that has their own
relationship line so of course we'll
have a lot of time to talk about that
one later but moving on through the list
here still in level two the toast of the
Town find the map chamber as a Slytherin
and then I'll just go ahead and tell you
the others as well there's also one
called the Orr's Apprentice find the map
chamber as a Hufflepuff the Gryffindor
in the graveyard find the map chamber as
a Gryffindor and then the wise owl find
the map chamber as a Ravenclaw so again
some terms that we haven't heard before
which is why I put it into level two and
it's those four trophies right there
that make me uncertain if we'll be able
to get this in a single playthrough now
the other possibility is that we could
do it with poly juice potion they've
already mentioned poly juice potion as
being part of the game so we know that
much part of me would be pretty shocked
if we would have to play through four
times as each house I know a lot of
people are going to do that anyway but I
would be shocked if we have to go
through four complete playthroughs now
there's a couple possibilities here like
I mentioned Polyjuice being one way
around it another possibility is that
maybe this is something you can do very
early in the game so maybe we could do
our initial play through as whichever
house we want get all the other trophies
and then maybe we only have to play the
game to a certain point as another house
so maybe you just have to make it
through that initial sorting ceremony
and then you can explore as a Hufflepuff
as a Ravenclaw Slytherin Gryffindor
whichever you know and then you could
just immediately go and find the map
chamber I don't know that one's going to
be interesting to see how that pans out
so after that we have one called Room
with a View reach the highest point in
the castle the headmaster's upper study
so I put this one here because it
essentially confirms that we will be
able to go to the headmaster's upper
study and I also think it's most likely
that it is Professor black all right the
next one we have one called spilled milk
this one might be my favorite in the
whole entire list and it is use
flippindo 10 times to tip one cow or
several so I know that was a lot there
right first off flopindo confirmed let's
go so excited that they included this as
even if it's just an Easter egg I think
this is hilarious and clearly with this
trophy with this achievement right here
it is being used in a humorous way so
tip one cow I mean is this gonna be out
in the field a kind of surrounding
Hogwarts kind of be funny if there's
just like some random room though where
you just cow tipping with pindo this one
just makes me smile more than any other
I I think it's going to be something
taking place outside of Hogwarts giving
us something else to do outside the
castle love to have flippindo confirmed
and love to hear that we're going to be
able to do something so humorous as
tipping cows with it kind of reminds me
of the old school Chamber of Secrets you
know tossing the Gnomes that's the first
thing I thought of as de-noming Mrs
Weasley's Garden all right after full
pindo we have one called Merlin's beard
and then to get this one you have to
complete all all the Merlin trials now
we knew Merlin puzzles were going to be
part of the game they talked about that
in the state of Play trailer now the
question just becomes how many right I
mean merla's beard complete all the
trials definitely gonna be a fun one and
I know my buddy expecto goes gonna be
pumped for that after that we have one
called the Intrepid Explorer discover
all Cairn dungeons so this is going way
back that phrase Cairn dungeon we
actually reported on that a while back
that that was the name they were using
internally I actually thought it was
just for one of the dungeons but now it
seems they have more than one Cairn
dungeon and so we're gonna have to
search for all of them to try and get
this trophy after that we have one
called coasting along visit poitzier
Coast so I looked this up I don't think
it's a real place however the word
poincier guess what it means in Scottish
Gaelic it means poacher of course we
already know poachers are in this game
and it seems this poicier Coast here is
probably going to be their main Hub
their Lair if you will where they're
hanging out and then finally our last
one here in the level two category is is
troll with the punches survived the
troll attack on hogsmead now that one
was also won very close to being put in
level one since we see that happening in
the trailer but just to be safe I
decided to go ahead and include it here
in level two alright so finally we have
reached level three spoilers and I have
included six here some are even more
spoilery than others I'm gonna work our
way up to what I think is the most
spoilery one of all and then to be
honest with you guys there's a lot that
is borderline here too I just I really
want to be safe and protect the people
who want absolutely no story spoilers at
all but I mean hey if you made it this
far you probably don't care so we're
gonna jump into it right now last chance
to turn back for level three spoilers
first up we have the hero of Hogwarts
defeat ranrock so the reason I put this
one here at level three because hey we
already knew about ran Rock we already
knew that we would probably be saving
Hogwarts right but I included it here in
level three because so many of us had
been actually thinking that ran Rock was
not the main villain and that there was
going to to be something else kind of
behind this that so it wasn't just ran
Rock and it wasn't just this Goblin
Rebellion it's kind of the main
antagonist of the game this to me
seemingly confirms that man rock is the
main villain I would be surprised now
very surprised if he wasn't the main
villain I'm a little disappointed in
that I was hoping that there was going
to be someone else a dark wizard behind
it that could be Rookwood but more on
Rookwood here in a second after that we
have one called grappling with a grab
horn and then to get this one you have
to subdue the lord of the shore so lord
of the shore as far as I know is not a
term we have came across in the Harry
Potter series in The Wizarding World
before my personal guess I think it's
highly likely this is tied to the
poydzir coast which is most likely going
to be the layer of the poachers in the
game now if you're someone who is hoping
hey maybe there is someone else above
ran Rock perhaps that is the lord of the
shore maybe this is even the masked
villain that we saw in the very first
reveal trailer or one of the mass
villains you know because we've seen
several of those at this point wearing
those skull masks all right next we have
the one who mastered memories view all
pensive memories now to be totally fair
here we all felt pretty strongly that we
had already seen some pensives in the
game but this here 100 confirms it and
it also opens up so many other
possibilities especially when it comes
to the story I mean that's the crazy
thing about a pensive is yeah even
though Hogwarts Legacy is taking place
in 1890 with a pensive that means we
could essentially go back to any time
period right and I don't know if we're
going to be playing through these
pensive sections or if it's just going
to be more something you watch like a
cut scene but that just opens up so many
possibilities and honestly has me pretty
excited to see then we have that's a
keeper meet Charles Rookwood in the map
chamber so I put this one in level three
because Charles Rookwood is not a name
we've heard before we heard Victor
Rookwood and Victor is the one that we
see in the trailer talking with ranrock
so there are really two possibilities I
think here Charles Brookwood is a
completely separate character or they
change the name of Victor to Charles
instead so we just talked about map
Chambers with that trophy relating to
the four houses and and then finding the
map chamber with each house now it also
seems there's a point in the game when
we need to meet up with this Charles
Rookwood character so are they possibly
Victor rookwood's son are they a student
are they an older Rookwood I mean
there's so many possibilities here are
they a Ravenclaw companion perhaps all
right now we're ready for the final two
rising from the ashes rescue the Phoenix
so that one I think it should be pretty
obvious why I put it here in level three
we did not have Phoenix's confirmed for
being in the game now we do and it also
seems pretty clear there's going to be a
mission and or side quest where we have
to rescue a phoenix and the final one
guys I think is gonna have a lot of
people excited it is called the hallowed
hero and to obtain this trophy you have
to wield a Deathly Hallow now we had
seen Deathly Hallows appear in the
Autodesk presentation but in name only
we had no idea how that was going to
impact the game now seemingly here we
have confirmation that at some point in
Hogwarts Legacy we are going to be
wielding one of the Deathly Hallows the
question is which one and also do we
have a choice how insane would that be
if you get to choose one of the three
Hallows in this game I don't know how
that would work because I feel like it
would just make it so game breaking
right if you choose the Elder Wand
obviously if you get the invisibility
cloak then that's going to make stealth
a lot easier the resurrection stone that
was a little more interesting I can't
really figure out how that would factor
into gameplay can certainly see some
ways they would use it in the story but
as far as gameplay I'm not so sure I
don't know maybe we're going to be
summoning spirits to fight alongside us
or something that'd be crazy but guys if
you watch this far please be respectful
of the others in the comments who do not
want any spoilers at all and if you
haven't seen my full reaction to the
Hogwarts Legacy gameplay showcase check
that video out next it's on the right
side of your screen now as always thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon